i've been having so much fun testing out
the latest beta software that we can
expect to see out here very shortly i've
been using it on my secondary laptop
which i highly recommend if you do have
an older device always install beta
software on something that is not your
main computer or your main phone now
before we get into some of my favorite
features a huge thank you to nerdwallet
for sponsoring this portion of this
video nerdwallet helps you make smart
financial decisions with side-by-side
comparisons of top credit cards savings
accounts and more now for everyday
things that we're buying like gas or
groceries or for me gadgets to review
here on my channel i like to use my
credit card i pay it off at the end of
the month so i'm still able to get those
extra rewards some cards you'll actually
be able to get cash back so having these
side-by-side comparisons are so great
because you'll be able to know that
you're getting the best rewards nerd
wallet lets you compare financial
products side by side with thorough
reviews and objective ratings so you can
choose the smartest credit card savings
account whatever financial product
you're looking for and find one that
works for you nerd wallet is the
smartest decision for all your financial
decisions thank you again to nerdwallet
for sponsoring that portion of this
video so i have mac os ventura over here
and this is installed on my secondary
computer this is on the 14 inch macbook
m1 pro i do not recommend installing any
beta software on your main devices
because these are still things that are
not fully completed yet so you really
don't know what's gonna happen you can't
fully trust it so don't say that i
didn't warn you apple warns you everyone
always warns you with that being said i
do have it installed and i've been using
it and i'm so excited for this to
actually be released normally with apple
schedules these things tend to come out
around the fall when the new iphones
come out so we can expect this sometime
around there let's hop in and check out
some of the features that i've been
really enjoying now the number one main
feature that is kind of new that is a
huge ui change is the stage manager so
to get stage manager started you can go
up here into this little selection
station it's the selection station
that's what we're calling it now
and you can click stage manager so this
gives you the stage manager option so
you can turn it on so as you start
opening things up let's see we're gonna
go to youtube
we've got that okay great love that
we're gonna open up some maps
and all of these things just kind of
start popping up and going over here
into the stage manager section so with
stage manager it's kind of giving you a
dock on the left hand side so you can
switch between all the things that you
have currently open
again you can toggle this on and off
just in here stage manager on stage
manager off and of course that works if
you have all of these things open which
is kind of nice because with it on you
basically just have a bunch of
things just here
everywhere so this is with it off and
it's kind of crazy because once you
start using it you get really used to
having kind of everything all neat and
kind of compact over on the side so now
we've got our
final cut pro open
so if i have this kind of in the mix
turn it all on look at that
so
nice
so nice so fresh
so clean another thing that's been
redesigned in ventura is the system
preferences and this desperately needed
to be redone because it was very hard to
kind of find things like everything was
sort of in these little icons but now
it's all in this nice list view which is
kind of similar to your iphone when you
go into the preferences and try to make
any sort of changes so you'll see here
we've got everything listed on the side
and i kind of like this new
organizational feature i also love being
able to search they did have this on the
previous version of mac os so if i want
to do some display settings i can just
directly search and it automatically
takes me directly to it which is pretty
exciting another thing is live text they
have these live captions that will pop
up when you're watching youtube videos
it also should work when you're on a
facetime call so let's test this out i
actually haven't tried this yet you can
turn on the live captions in facetime
and the live captions
here on the mac so let's
try to watch a youtube video so let's
let's do it here we go
yeah we're moving and grooving now i'm
actually pretty impressed how quickly it
was able to translate the text now
normally on a lot of my youtube videos i
do have closed captions already but this
is great for videos where there aren't
any closed captions or even some
facetime calls okay so here's the
facetime
live captions we're calling jake hi
hey how's it going uh it's going good
how are you
i'm doing pretty good i was just about
to go for a run nice and i got the
surprise call how's your day going so
far it's going great just filming a
little video actually you're on camera
here wow i bet you didn't know that did
you
i had no idea about the cameras i just
set up how's it going what were you
running at
uh i was about to run the one trail over
by the thing that's near the place oh
that sounds fun i like that that's cool
okay well i'm gonna hit this run and
then i'll come back
and for behind the cameras in just a
moment okay bye
oh my god
another feature that i've been loving on
ios 16 just on my phone is the send and
unsend imessages now this is pretty
exciting i feel like this is something
that a lot of people have been wanting
for a very long time now not only will
you be able to do that on your phone but
you'll also be able to do that here on
your desktop so i have just sent my
sister some messages hello
hi
how are you
how's everything
you good
i'm just going to right click on this
one and i'm going to undo send oh look
at that it's gone
do you want to go to
the mall
and then i'm going to now edit that
because i don't want to go to the mall i
want to go
to
the
movies
yeah there we go okay so as you can see
this will show you where you've unsent
messages and this will also show you
where you've edited a message which is
pretty helpful because you don't want
people to be able to abuse this so this
gives you a clear line of what was
happening and what was edited passkeys
is also something that i'm very excited
about it's not fully fleshed out yet but
one of the other things that you are
able to do now in passwords is you're
able to delete old wi-fi passwords and
you're able to change and edit the
suggested passwords so when you go and
sign up for something in safari and you
need a password it'll give you the
suggestion but you can't ever actually
edit or change that it's just like hey
here's your suggestion this is now your
password good luck have fun but now you
can actually edit and change that so i'm
very excited about that they've also
made some changes to mail which is kind
of cool because this sort of is what
gmail has been doing on the web for
quite a while you can schedule messages
to be sent later you can undo sends and
you can also have follow-up reminders so
if you haven't emailed someone back then
you know it'll give you a gentle
reminder of like you may want to write
back to this email i also like having
the focus features being so readily
accessible here because
right now i actually have it on sleep
because my sleep mode i have
notifications completely off so i'm
filming i know that i can have my sleep
mode i'm not gonna have things popping
up but a lot of times you can also
customize these but for me i just put it
on sleep and i know that there's no
notifications whatsoever there's also
another little option where you have the
share across devices so if i set my
computer to sleep my iphone my apple
watch everything else that is connected
to this apple id will also say that i'm
sleeping it doesn't actually say you're
sleeping but you know what i mean this
will give you a focused status update so
if somebody does message me it'll say
hey this person is not getting
notifications at this time but you can
choose to notify them anyway
if you're that type of person and i know
you're out there
those type of people one of the things
that i'm excited to try is the facetime
handoff now this is one of those
scenarios where you're on a facetime
call maybe outside you get in your house
and you're at your computer and you want
to transfer that call to your computer
now before you weren't able to do this
but now this makes it super simple to go
from your phone to your computer if you
want to do the facetime call on there so
let's test it out i'm going to make a
call here i'm going to call jake here
on my phone
hi
uh hi i i never got to finish my i never
got to finish my run but hi welcome back
that's fine um yeah how's everything
going wow okay well i'm gonna do
something now i'm going to transfer this
call to my laptop so to do this there's
a little button up here that shows that
i'm on facetime so i'm now going to
click that i'm going to switch to my
computer so now that i've switched to my
computer i then click join
and now this gives me the little option
on my phone that shows that it is
switching to my mac so it says that i
can move the call to this phone so now i
am on my phone voila and then if i'm on
my computer i'm gonna go over here click
switch join
and now
i'm on the mac dude
how was it did it work
uh it was like magic this little square
popped up and you flipped and now you're
a square yourself wow and also the live
text is still on so now i'm getting the
live text while you're chatting well you
know i do enjoy utilizing gargantuan
idioms to fabricate intelligence oh this
is a good time oh my oh boy
um have a good run
thank you bye bye so that was the
facetime handoff now we're gonna try
something else that has to do with
facetime we're gonna be using this
little disc here to use continuity
camera now this allows me to mount my
phone onto my macbook now they don't
currently have a mount for your desktop
computer yet so i did try to mount that
on my studio display and i was like wait
this is basically made just for the
laptop so using this little magsafe disk
we attach this to the back of
your phone and then we just
go like this put it onto your laptop and
now when you're in facetime this is
going to give you the option to choose
to use the iphone 13
as your main camera source so right now
i'm still using the facetime camera and
we go up here to video we're going to
switch this to iphone 13 pro camera so
let's do that
and now voila we're now using center
sage so let's call
let's call jake back again
he's never gonna get his run completed
[Music]
oh hi
i was on my run and i fell oh you have
fallen okay well since you're there i'm
gonna show you something so here is the
desk view you can also zoom out a little
too and that will kind of show you more
of the area but let me show you what
this looks like if i have like a piece
of paper and i write something
hello how are you
i'm
great so this is actually using the
ultra wide camera and it's using ai to
then distort that image to make it look
like it's a top-down camera when this is
obviously not a top-down camera but it's
pretty impressive okay i'm gonna show
you something tell me tell me what you
see
okay
dude
do you see it
i'm good how are you you are great wow
hello jake whoa this is so this is so
cool because i can see you
and the desktop on top of you no way
really and i can actually move it around
so i'm still visible this is so cool i
was just writing this is so cool how did
you know there's like three squares on
my facetime right now there's me in the
top right you on top and then on the
bottom is your desk view wow
wow that's so cool well that's actually
a cool function so you can screen share
while i'm still seeing you too no way
that's so cool no this is exciting so
i'm screen sharing and showing you my
desk view at the same time bye jake
well thank you guys so much for watching
i hope you guys enjoyed this little look
at mac os ventura i am so looking
forward to this new update now normally
when these updates come out i do tend to
wait at least three to six months just
because a lot of the plugins that i have
for final cuts for a lot of my audio
interfaces those don't update right away
so i do tend to wait but i am very
excited for the release and it's been
really fun to get a chance to test this
out on my secondary devices but for most
people you should be perfectly fine to
update when the release is out again i
just tend to wait but that's just me if
you guys are new here hi welcome thank
you so much for checking out my channel
i'm justine if i didn't tell you that
already if you haven't already be sure
to subscribe to my youtube channel so
you'll be able to see all of the videos
that i post in the near future be sure
to hit the bell so you'll be notified
when i do post those videos and leave me
some comments below and let me know what
kind of content you guys like to watch
i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]